so today we are at another fun until the
button I just realized I never posted
the block last we did I did you can
watch it on my channel thanks for here
route to Rises international drone day
today I'm quite pumped up about it
[Music]
so his birthday
I guess
Island
so how's that real thing it's gonna kind
of tie into germs that can be able to
set that there's something in front of
it she was not going to help alleviate
any of those crashes like you were
talking about yep we actually have an
example of one here and you can see the
little black module on top is actually
the six realsense cameras so ladies and
gentlemen
[Music]
you gotta love the live feed of it right
there on my TV all right the Intel
experience sweepstakes winner is Freddy
Oh congratulations
I think I think these do you guys have a
YouTube channel
yeah I think you're gonna start one now
aren't you with this drone maybe I don't
know Oh congratulations now you have to
make a speech shoes no it's okay
well the congratulations everyone my mom
enter really Samia centers up our Best
Buy event and now we're going to block
their diner which I don't know if you
guys remember or not but this is where
we went when we were in Squibb I can't
believe it I thought it was like a local
a local I'm also gonna unbox the drone
when I get in here what do you think
going on right now it's international
drone day by the time at this this long
three days way over
holy moly put stickers around you
I'm shaking guys and things are
happening right now I'm not sure I feel
like this might be a bigger process than
I have time for at lunch but look at you
and your little sis - nomes - okay
pre-loading successful this is a lot
easier than I thought it was I just push
the button
emergency landing
we gotta go outside over here alright
it's a it's connected you can get so far
away from my phone instead of just
thought of that
an amuse
[Music]